hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i
am a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be answering your property
investment questions
so if you've got any questions about
property
business finance tax mortgages lease
option agreements rent to rents
tenants comment them below in the
comment box and
next week i'm going to be answering your
question also don't forget to subscribe
because if you comment below and i
answer your question next week you might
not even know that i answered it because
you weren't subscribed and you missed
the video
so smash the subscribe button turn the
notification bell on and if you like my
videos please do me a massive favor
and smash the like button the thumb
should be pointing up and it should be
blue
so let's see what questions we had last
week so we had a question from alex
thompson who said
what legal documents do you need to
start co-deal sourcing
as i want to use this as funds to start
a deal
sourcing company and leverage to buy
properties by the way i highly
appreciate all what you do for people
thank you so much alex
so what documents do you need to do
co-deal sourcing the good news is you
don't need any documents
you don't need anything to start coding
your sourcing all you need is deals
because code deal sourcing is when you
find a deal
and then you pass it to a deal saucer
and the deal
saucer sells it and deals with
everything and all the paperwork and you
just get paid so the only thing that you
might want
is you might want an agreement between
you and the deal
saucer but this you could write yourself
you could get an nda but to be honest
you don't absolutely need it you just
need a deal saucer that you can trust to
begin with so
that's my advice so go knock yourself
out and go make some money
harley barton is there a minimum age for
rent to rent and deal sourcing and if so
what is it
um listen harley there there is and that
isn't
so minimum age for property investing so
to buy a house you generally need to be
18.
in fact to get a contract or just about
to do anything you normally need to be
18
to get a buy to let mortgage you need to
be 21 however
don't let that stop you i was just with
a guy today
his name is joshua and i was in hall and
joshua bought
his first house he's bought it he's
refinanced it
he's pulled all his money out by 63
pounds
great little house he is 18 years old i
met him when he was 17 years old and
i've mentored him and trained him
and he's 18. how did he do it he did it
because he got his parents
to be a host and to be a guarantor
for him for the property so that was his
solution and there's lots of other
things you can do so
if you the thing is if you are valuable
if you can find good deals everything
else will fall into place so never let
age stop you
if believe me if you're 16 years old but
you can find
really good houses that are worth 200
grand but you negotiate them down to 150
50 000 discount do you think everyone's
gonna go no not interested you're only
15.
no no interesting no the market
doesn't discriminate whether you are
black white woman man
1550 no one cares
the only thing we care about as a
marketplace and as an economy
is that you can provide value so that's
that and also
you can always flip the cards if you
feel disadvantaged because you're a
woman or because you're younger because
you're old or whatever it might be
remember most of mostly that's in your
head now i'm not saying that there are
sometimes disadvantages
but the thing is you can flip the cards
and what i mean by that is you can turn
your disadvantage
into an advantage an example of that
would be when i started i was 17 years
old
i had no education i was not experienced
i had no money and i'm a teenager
i flipped the cards because what i did
was i started getting around people who
were property investors
and i started helping them and working
for them for free and because i was
young
it was almost like an excuse to not have
loads of knowledge so i could ask
questions that people who were 37
wouldn't have the bottle to ask
but i'm like i'm 17. it's all good and
what i found was i flipped the cards
and people started helping me because i
was young
they're like this kid's pretty
knowledgeable he's pretty
courageous he's got good energy he's
young
and people wanted to help me because i
was young so that's what i mean by
flipping the cards
and and you everyone's dealt cards
everyone's given cards and what i mean
by that is you're born
and everyone's got different situations
we're not born the same
where some people are born into a rich
family a poor family and everyone's
some people go through university their
parents fund them others can't have the
opportunity to do that so we're all
candid different cards in life you gotta
look at your cards
and then play the game to win and deal
your cards the best you possibly can
and make the most of your situation so
if you're young just go for it
and find solutions don't find problems
don't find excuses
find value and then go and crush the
marketplace hope you find that helpful
again smash the like button if you
enjoyed this video
if you're finding it useful all right
next question is from
ciaran he says hi i've got a development
i've got 50
of the money needed how do i get
investors i don't want to use any sort
of finance
i hate to break it to you but if you're
looking for investors that is finance
so if you if you've got 50 of the money
i don't know why you don't want finance
but just go get finance
i don't that doesn't to me it doesn't
sound logical i don't want to get a
mortgage but i want to find the money
from private investors
i don't know if there's a reason if it's
a religious reason maybe
if so fair enough i respect that but
from a commercial viewpoint i'm not
quite sure
where you're coming from so maybe ask me
another question with a bit more detail
around the circumstances and i'll do my
best to help
hope that helps says hey samuel if you
refinance your house do you have to pay
stamp duty or any type of taxes
no you do not pay any taxes if you
refinance your house and you do not pay
stamp duty
andrew taylor says hope you're well
samuel my question is is it wise
to refinance your own home to purchase
my own
brr property i'm a builder who would do
a lot of work myself
and anything i can't do i have brilliant
links for andrew taylor
yes i would say it is wise to do that
because if you've got equity in your own
home
and you have the ability to take that
money out of your home
and put it into a property which you can
buy add value as a builder
refinance geez you could take that money
you could put it back into your home now
you've got two houses
or you could take the money back and
then go do the same thing with a third
house
and recycle and recycle and grow your
wealth so
100 i often find with builders
and to be honest a lot of property
professionals
and i would say a builder is a property
professional
and a maybe a property tax accountant
a construction officer a letting agent
an estate agent
they're really good at property and
they're really good at making other
people money
but sometimes when it comes to making
money themselves in the game
they have a mental blank or they don't
quite they don't quite get it so
of course it makes sense andrew go take
that equity
grow it make money you've got the skills
you've got the links and keep
you posted how you get on jonathan says
could you give some tips on how to
secure
direct bookings for serviced
accommodation rather than through
otas which is online travel agents so
yeah if you want to get direct bookings
i mean of course you can set up a little
website you can make a website on wix
for free and it can be
your own thing which can have a calendar
on it
the best way to get direct bookings
though is to
keep a crm system a customer relations
management system and again you can use
something like
mailchimp or all clients which are
peanuts next to nothing it might cost
you
nothing to 20 pound a month and when you
get
a booking through booking.com or whoever
the ota
is keep the person's details booking.com
is no different from like a dating
agency
what they're doing is they're bringing
you the
owner or the or the ocu the person who's
got the accommodation
with someone that wants to stay there so
if you keep their details and then
you grow your list of people that stayed
there once that means they've stayed
there
they probably liked it maybe they left
your review and then
every so often you can message them and
just say hey i know you stayed here
before
we're doing a special offer come back so
you're gonna grow your list
um that's probably the best way to get
direct bookings if you get people from
direct bookings it's good because you
don't pay any fees
booking.com charged like 15 so you're
saving straight away so you can afford
to offer discounts
also if you get direct bookings because
they've been to the property before
and they like it you tend to get people
that stay longer which is also really
really nice so hope that helps and i
hope that um
you kill it in service accommodation
next
mahabhara i hope i pronounced that right
i'm sure i didn't
my question is can you write up the nda
contract by yourself or does it have to
be from a solicitor great content by the
way
16 years old hoping one day to be on
winners on a wednesday
you're going to be on winners on the
wednesday i have no doubt so
you can drop in nda yourself an nda by
the way for anyone that doesn't know is
a non-disclosure agreement
and honestly people think
that for a contract to be legally
binding you need to have a solicitor
draw it
up this is completely not the case if a
contract has been drawn up even if it's
just
an email thread if it's black and white
and it's clear and it's in plain english
with no solicitor
it is legally binding in court and i've
had i've gone to court
in the past and i've won based
on literally an email thread or a
contract that i just banged up myself
in 10 minutes and 10 minutes so
sometimes you do want a solicitor to
come on board and write the contracts if
it's a complicated thing
or if you're doing an agreement where
you can't afford it to go wrong because
there's a lot of money at stake
100 percent get a solicitor or if you're
buying a house of course guess lister
but to have a confidentiality agreement
or an nda agreement
you could get a system to draw it up but
don't think that you can't do it
yourself and don't think that it's not
legally binding just because you drew it
up yourself because that's not the case
and i wouldn't suggest for a 16 year old
like yourself you start spending
hundreds or maybe even thousands of
pounds against listeners drop contracts
if if you're 16 you probably haven't got
much money you've not got much to lose
i'd probably just write something in
plain english but i can't advise because
i don't know exactly what you're talking
about but i hope you found that helpful
and next burning desire
i samuel just a topic i was thinking
back of
my head which may change the mentality
of many people
like it do rich people buy their cars on
finance or should they cash
it out based on how you mentor people i
think you'll say finance it
and invest what you have in the bank is
this leverage good or is it bad debt
so burning desire i would generally
probably guide people
to lease their vehicles now
just to be really transparent my range
rover i do own that i did buy that car
and it's funny i have to almost put like
a disclaimer that i own it normally be
the other way around normally but like i
lease it
but but for me because i i preach at
least what you own
the only reason i bought my range rover
i don't know why i bought it i just
really really really liked it and i've
leased cars for a very long time and
i can i i had plenty of money i just
thought why not buy it
and also the leasing was so expensive i
don't actually think it worked out much
different because i wanted to have the
car for a long time
i paid 126 000 pounds to buy my range
rover
but generally it makes sense to lease it
and here's why because it's same with a
house it makes sense to lease your house
anything that's not going to give you
money anything that's not an asset you
should just
lease it and then you should use your
money to buy assets which give you money
and then that money yeah they're going
to lease
i know it's a bit of a mind shift for
some people but this this is
a more commercially savvy way to do
business it makes more financial sense
and it's what most rich people do
certainly people that i know that are
wealthy so i hope that helps thank you
so much for your question
all right rishi says hey man show us how
to find a deal
and do proper due diligence on it take a
few examples on a youtube video like
seeing eg 10 properties or more and
making sure it's a deal
okay and then there's more of an idea
than a question but
i like it so basically you want me to go
out
view a whole bunch of houses and then go
around the houses and talk about which
one i want and which ones i don't and
why
in the dude okay good good idea i will
note that
i'll tell my videographer who's behind
the video note that and
i'll do that at some point in fact if i
i love this if you've got any ideas if
you want to see me do something on
youtube or if you've got any
challenges or any ideas or things you
want to learn things you want to see as
well as just questions
comment them below i read every single
comment okay next brian says hey samuel
i've been a subscriber for a couple
months now loving your videos man keep
it up
i'm 19. i love having these teenagers on
here so cool
last last week we had like a 70 year old
asking questions now we've got 19 year
olds and it's awesome
i'd like to be a property investor and
have got a small amount in savings
with stamp duty being cut out until
march i am lost on what strategy to
pursue
to get my foot through the door in
property do i raise finance and pursue a
brr strategy
or do i pursue rent to rent or lease
options and possibly miss the window of
paying no stamp duty would like to know
your take
okay brian firstly the whole stamp duty
holiday thing
that is not for investors that's for if
you're buying a house to live in so
this whole idea of missing the window
that sorry to break it to you but that
doesn't apply
however the good news is if you're doing
brr as a strategy
you're probably not going to pay stamp
duty anyway because brr is when you buy
a house
normally that's unmortgageable and then
you refurbish it and then you refinance
it and then you rent it but if you're
buying a house that's unmortgageable
you're probably not going to pay stamp
duty anyway because if you're buying a
house that's inhabitable you're not
going to pay stamp duty
however don't let the tail wag the dock
don't think
how can i avoid stamp duty how can i how
can i choose a strategy that help with
this tax efficient
you want to think about how can i choose
a strategy that's going to make me the
most money that's going to serve my
goals
so what i would say is um what do you
want from property properties of
vehicles you want cash flows you want to
build wealth and get capital
appreciation
what do you want do you want to replace
your income and and then decide what
your personal goals are in business
and then find a strategy forget the
whole standard you think just find a
strategy that's going to
serve you in your journey and then go
out to town and
kill that one strategy and focus in on
that one strategy so
hope that helps and good luck okay next
lisa ross would you need planning
permission to turn a four-bedroom house
into a hmo
no you will only need planning
permission if it's in an article four
area or if you're turning it into a
seven bedroom or more
hope that helps lois says hi samuel if
you were to do a rent to rent would you
have to be responsible for all the
repairs on the property or can you set
an agreement
on who repairs what love your videos
thanks so no
you don't have to do all the repairs
it's whatever you agree so you could get
them to do the repairs
or you could do the repairs but if
you're doing the repairs make sure that
you have a
limiter on it so the rent-to-rent deal
you'll say i'll take care of the repairs
as long as it's not more than 400 pounds
and as long as it's not an external
problem and what that means is
with properties if there's ever repairs
it's either an internal or an external
repair an internal repair will be
something to do with the inside of the
house
it's internal the door breaks or
something internal
external will be something like there's
a leaky roof it's on the outside of the
property so you always want to make sure
that the landlord or the owner
deals with the external problems with
the house and
make sure that there's a limiter because
you don't want the boiler to break and
cost you
1500 two months into the rent to rent
agreement
and then you have to fix it so you're
gonna say look if it's something small
i'll fix it
but it's whatever you agree and it's
whatever you put in the contract
okay i'm just gonna do maybe one or
maybe two more questions again if you're
enjoying it smash the
like button so ammar when you mention
pull all your money out in brr do you
mean you get
back that money into your bank account
also when people mention how they leave
a few thousand pounds in the property
once refurbished and refinanced what
does that mean
yes amar it means you get the money back
in your bank account isn't it brilliant
and what that means if you pull most of
your money up and all of it
is so you buy a house say you buy for a
hundred thousand pounds
you then spend fifty thousand pounds on
it so all in you put 150 in
now that might not be your money that
might be bridging money it could be
investors money but you put 150 in
if the new valuation is now one uh 200
you're going to then get a new finance
you're going to refinance
and you're going to pull out 75 percent
of the new value so 75 percent of the
new value
would be 150 grand so if you put in 150
and then you value it at 200 which is
the new value you're going to pull out
all your money
but if it's down valued you put 150 in
you push the value up and now it's only
worth 190
when you refinance you're going to leave
10 grand in the deal
so you're gonna get all the money out
back in your bank
bar ten thousand pounds so i hope that
helps i know it's a little bit
complicated to get your head around
but it's a really really good strategy i
do also i am going to be running a
webinar
on buy refurbished refinance real soon
so i'll leave a link in the description
with the buy refurbished refinance
webinar check it out
free webinar i go into great detail
about how this strategy works that'll be
with me personally and it's free
hope that helps okay last question mike
kingsnorth
hi samuel i'm a massive fan and you've
inspired me to get to property i've
bought my first house which i've turned
into a five bed hml oh
fantastic and just about to complete on
my second property
and have an offering on my third dude
that's incredible you need to maybe
think about
applying for wins on a wednesday go to
winners on a wednesday dot com
and maybe you need to come on my channel
and i can interview you and you can
share your experience because this is
sounding awesome
also if you're not already on samuel 365
get on that get on that samuel 365.com
you're going to get mentoring training
coaching
starting from one pound it's just insane
so go check that out samuel 365.com
things move very quickly and i can't
thank you enough for your videos my
question is though
how much do you make from youtube
um strange question i know but i'd love
to also start helping others via this
platform well
there we go um and if making more money
is a byproduct of helping others then
i'm all in uh mike king's north how much
do i make from youtube off the top of my
head i don't know how much i make from
youtube
but i'm very happy to talk about how
much i make from youtube if you want to
know how much i make from youtube folks
put it in the comment box below just say
yes samuel
reveal how much you make from youtube
i'll do a whole video about it and i'll
show
the screenshots of how much i make from
youtube believe it or not i don't make
that much from doing this
it's this is for me more about
helping people because i believe that if
you help people get what they want
ultimately you'll get what you want
so the joint ventures that i get and the
branding that i get and the fulfillment
that i get
is really why i do youtube that's why i
don't even know how much i make doing
youtube
but for sure i can check and i'll let
you know
if you want to see it comment below and
i don't want to do a whole video about
it if no one cares so if you care
please do comment and let me know guys i
love you folks thank you so much for
watching this thank you for your
questions thank you for your success
because your success
is my oxygen if you're not subscribed
already you can do that right here
and honestly if you don't subscribe and
you watch my videos bad things are going
to start happening to you
alright subscribe turn the notification
bell on i'll see you next time
[Music]
you